Oh, hello there.
Good afternoon, how doing?
Okay.
Yeah, doing pretty good.
Is my camera not working? Oh, there it goes. There you go.
Hmm.
Alex is going to be joined.
He should be, yes, we just got off another call.
How's your day so far?
It's been busy. How about you?
Yeah, same here. Pre busy.
Yeah.
So we're out for last like Monday was out, so we went for a team outing. So I took my team to a hilly mountain area for three days trip.
Nice.
So, um, what I assume camping? Tents?
Yeah, tense, and we, so what we do do normally, like every engineer pod that I have for the engineer that works, you know, and reports to me, we take them for a team every quarter, so just kind of a one-on-one connect. Yeah, I think Aleks joins.
Oh.
We're discussing Alex when what we do here. Every quarter we take our team to for outing. We plan for a travel and where we stay together, discuss, you know, everything. So kind of one-on-one connect, kind of build a personal relation out of. So only we discuss about.
the party and everything. No office work, nothing. Just one-on-one connect.
When is that happening?
No, it happened last week. We, after the shift in the morning, we traveled Saturday, we stay Saturday, Sunday, then Monday was holiday, so Monday evening we reached home, you know. So it was two day, almost three days trip.
Wow, that's amazing.
And follow this exercise.
That's awesome.
every quarter. If maybe due to any reason, if not able to travel, that we maybe order food together, kind of have a potluck together and bring individual dishes and then enjoy the dinner, lunch together. Maybe go to a restaurant and have a dinner together.
That's great, man. That's awesome. Love it. I love it.
So I had a lot of conversations. I just hung up with 1/2 hour call with Karen, so we just came from one back to back. And we had an intense call, you know, you were on the call yesterday with me and Animesh, and then like that tail end of that call, you know, got, I think, a little bit more.
Ankur.
Yeah.
Um...
You know, I guess I'm more frustrated from my side, you know, a little bit like regarding some of the conversation, but today's like bounce back always, like it seems like Animesh bounces back really well and responds really well. And this is the problem, he actually said this, it was a clue a few weeks ago.
Because.
He seems to respond to like negative energy, like, you know, like in a positive way, which doesn't help. Like, it's not like, you know, like I want that, but I see that sometimes as a character trait where people have adopted a habit where, you know, until somebody starts yelling about something, they don't take it seriously. And then they're like, oh, thank you.
and then they thank you or they apologize and then they fix their ways. So, you know, I could probably point to the exact moment when I heard that during a call a few weeks ago where I was like, ah, it clued me in a little bit like that. Again, I think people need to
Our goal, like, is to uplift our professionalism across the board, you know, so that we're focused on, you know, the outcomes and the results and allow people the freedom and space and time. Like, look at the amazing thing that you and you and Anna Mesh worked on today. I think that was great. Yeah, I mean, I don't even know how you...
put that into Excel, but you know, it's a really, really cool graphic inside of Excel. What's that? Did I open the Excel file? No, I didn't open it directly. No, I just saw the screenshot. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Have you checked the Excel too?
Did you check the Excel? Yeah.
No, try it open. You'll see that magic on that side too.
Yeah, beautiful magic, you know. So, you know, you're a talented man, so I really, really appreciate that. That's cool. That's really cool. You know, and of course, you know, you guys leverage Claude to build it, I imagine as well, yeah. So.
No, that's right, because, yeah, I mean, I have planned specific for, you know, Animes to be a daily connect for one hour to kind of just go through what all he's doing, what all the stuff, you know, if he need any support or anything that I can help him. So, every day in the afternoon, I have scheduled a one-hour connect, so today.
Mhm.
When I reached office, then I connected him for another one hour. Kind of helped him to understand what he needs to review all the server that he's upgrading, you know, what all the stack, you know, where he needs support and updating the notes, etc. to get ConnectWise. So that's going to give me the overview, what all he's doing, you know.
Mhm, mhm.
Yeah, I mean, I Pre, that's great. One hour a day, that's awesome. I mean, that's going to really help him along a lot. I mean, he needs that mentorship and support. And if I had the ability to, I mean, look, again, it's one of these challenges, like what roles do I fill and what roles do I need other people to fill?
And so, yeah, I'm just trying to fill in all the seats, right? So on a technical level, the challenge, you know, the challenge for me is that, again, I want to make sure I'm removed operationally from the technical side of things completely.
Yeah.
No.
So that's, I really, I'm very grateful that you're doing that on a daily basis with him. He's a great guy. He's a good guy.
No, yeah, of course. And I haven't appointed another person that's the VIM specialist. So who normally come in the day shift. So, you know, after maybe in the afternoon and the morning, he will be covering everything if you need any support or anything. So he'll be helping him.
Mhm.
All right, good. I think the core education piece is a part that even, you know, even Claude, like I was shocked yesterday, I asked, I asked Sonamish, I said, have you, have you used Claude? You know, do you have Claude Cowork installed? You know, do you have that? And he's like, no, I didn't install it. And I, and I took.
Yeah.
Like I jumped on his computer remote. I was like, or we were in a remote session already. I said, oh no, the clod is right there. It's on your system tray. I was like, did you click the tab?
Just click the other, you know, it says chat and then cowork, and then you click cowork. And I say, you know, you can actually, you know, use a folder in cowork and you can do things and, you know, and all this stuff. Yeah, so, you know, and then also that like you pointed out in the, you know, Excel, you sent the screenshot today of like the claud icon, like very clearly, okay, that's where you click to.
Yeah.
Create your own project, yeah.
But these things I want, this is why I keep, I'm shocked when I find myself after using a product for a long period of time, you know, or even a short period of time, that they're not learning about the products that we, that we roll out. So, you know, I just, I signed everybody last week up for Scribe. You know, Scribe?
So Scribe is a great tool for, you know, creating documentation, right? Standard operating procedures. So, you know, everybody, I license everybody with Scribe. See, I'm not, I'm not shy, as you could tell, like you gave me that thumbs up today. I buy everything. I buy everything. I buy all the software. Everybody's got Copilot licenses. Everybody's got Claude licenses. Everybody's got.
Yeah, skip.
Yeah, that's right, subscribe.
Exactly.
Nice tattoo, by the way. Everybody's got, you know, now scribe licenses, and we have a lot of other products. You know, they got the education. We actually, Empath is another education platform that they have full access to. And, you know, so we have a full non-blocking, like everybody can gain.
Thank you.
Yeah.
access to all of our vendor training programs as well, which I, you know, steered Animesh towards early on as well. But so that's sort of my challenge is like, especially Claude, it's like, no, you got to like, everybody's got to advance their level, you know, I can't coach everybody through this.
No, it's all good.
Kour.
They got like, you know, they got like cowork, you know, was there, was there the whole time, you know, so like, you know, explore the products. One of the things I thought of for Anna Mesh was like, because yesterday during the call, he, you know, sent me a message, he said,
You know, he asked me to look at something and says, well, Alex, the VM upgrade won't go, it won't work because of the ESXI host. I said, okay, well, do you know where to see the ESXI host inside the VMware backup disaster recovery infrastructure?
And he says, no. And I'm like, well, did you go through the training through, you know, three weeks ago? But what I thought of is, like, curiosity is key. Like, you know, like, you know, he's got to just click around every screen. Like, you can't expect to know everything unless you've clicked through every single screen.
Yeah.
And then you have to ask yourself, do you understand that screen, right? And what do I do at this screen? So I think that he needs to do that in Veeam, you know, in the Veeam backup disaster recovery consoles. He's got to do that in the Veeam service provider console. He's got to do that in the Veeam One console.
We go.
And then you have to read documentation, you know, because you can't just ask Claude questions forever. Like that's not necessary. You should ask Claude questions because I've done it myself. I've gone into Claude. I've troubleshot something for three hours and went completely down the wrong rabbit's hole, right? Because Claude will, you know, or whatever AI product you use,
Yeah.
Give you this step, yeah.
You know, you start going down these roads and you have to have enough knowledge not to go down the wrong roads because it'll start taking you down the wrong road. So the baseline, the base knowledge is extremely important, right? The formal knowledge of a product is extremely important because, you know, now we can't just have AI replace the version. People used to use Google, right? It's like, I'll go to Google and find the.
Yeah.
your answer. But that's also not, that wasn't a good approach either. You're either trained, like you know the product well enough. Sure, you use Google as a reference, but you don't use it as a means of like, like that's not your entire methodology, right? So that's, I think, really important for the whole team to understand as we expand is like whatever area that we're working in.
Like when Sameer starts next week, he'll be working in VMware A lot. And he can't just, you know, he just needs to know VMware. And how do you do that? Well, okay, click through all the screens, read like the manuals as well, because don't just wait for the time or troubleshooting. Like, you know, what is a data store? What does that look like? What does it look like when the data store is getting full? What are all the...
Yeah.
the files inside the data store, how are those all, you know, referenced through the VMware, you know, guests and, you know, how do you add, remove memory, how do you, you know, how do you do all of these things, right? I think it's extremely important. So I think Samar is going to obviously have more, I'm excited about Samar is a very great compliment to Animesh.
Good, yeah.
You know, I think his skill set's going to be very complementary.
That's right.
No, of course, you know, he, we just continue, yeah, right, Sameer, so he already has experience about MSP, right? And of course, technology wise, he know in and out every technology build infra from the scratch, you know, that, that's I think the most benefit for us, right? So I think he...
Hi, Sameer.
Probably also can support, you know, fill that gap. So once we have the proper planning, so that no, I mean, Vincent and Shivani, they are already aligned what they need to do, what part of their job is to going to be 40, 60% delivery on security side, is going to 30% on the VM.
backup and plus the mix work that he's going to do.
Yeah, yeah. I'm glad you brought that back up, those percentages we were talking about before.
Yeah, so because he was not clear. I think he's good at the technology side, but I think I asked him, you know, if he's not sure, get a clarity, you know, because if he's not clear what need to be done, what was the ask, it'll be create a problem. So I think he was a little confused that what is going to be my job is going to mix helping user.
The.
working on the back end or you know working on the server. So that I give him the clarity what all the role responsibility that he's going to take care. So he's main focused on on the VM backup as of now. Now he get the idea that what he need to done. So most of this time going to spend on the VM side taking care of the back. Yeah.
Oh, that was clear. I mean, if he didn't understand that, I mean, I literally, I said, that's all I want you to focus on until we, you know, until a certain point. But yeah, thank you for, you know, reiterating, reiterating that with him. So.
When I ask specific him today, if he's not sure about anything, asking 10 time will not impact anything, but doing anything without knowing what he need to do, you know, that's that create a problem later, you know, because your perception is that an image is aligned, right? So, after spending a few weeks.
I came to know, you came to know, and the task is not done, so I fill those all gaps, uh, you know, connected individually, one-on-one, but all three, to make sure they are aligned, what they need to do, follow, you know.
Yeah, we're going to get hopefully a lot more literal on execution, like in a very literal sense regarding execution on the cybersecurity side, and then infrastructure side, and you know, when Sameer joins us next week. We're waiting for the computer to be set up, and then
I got off a call earlier with Amit today.
you know, and so we're potentially going to have them on board on Monday. A handover call is not scheduled until we have the hardware confirmed. So, but we're going to start them out for the first week from 8 A.m. to 5 P.m. and then Sameer is going to go on to a
5 A.m. to 2 P.m. shift.
So he'll overlap with, so Anamesh will be in from 2 A.m. starting at 2 A.m. Then Sameer comes in starting at 5 A.m. And then Shivani and Vincent start at 8 A.m.
Hey there.
And then we're actually going to shift Vincent, not, you know, actually have to tell anybody yet, but I talked to Amit about it. We'll be probably towards the end of June. We're going to shift Vincent to a 10 A.m. start.
And then I'll work from 10 A.m. till...
Yeah.
Till 7 or till yeah, 7 P.m. so.
So the schedule is going to be, I mean, of course, if there is any change, we'll make that adjustment, but it's going to be kind of the fixed schedule. They're going to work on particular shift.
Yeah.
For like anime, yeah. So because the reason probably you know we discussed in the last call, we'll probably have to make those arrangements for the cab, you know, everything to in according to be the other staff to make sure they get the transport and everything on time.
Mhm.
Mm.
Yeah, so we a week to really two weeks ahead of time, right? You want to know two weeks is what you want, so you know, so since, but we went over the specifically Samara, because Sameer was there was actually no schedule set, right? So, that's something we're...
Two weeks, yeah, right, exactly, yeah, right.
Yeah.
First week is going to 8 to 8 to 5 for summer.
Doing out the gate.
Yeah, 8 to 5 and then and then for Sameer and then and then the week after next week, assuming he comes in next week, June 1, then the very next week, June 8th, he'll start to the 5 A.m. to 2 P.m.
Atul.
Yeah.
June Night.
And then we're going to let him get his feet wet and figure things out for a few weeks. Of course, he's more experienced. So once he is, you know, once we're comfortable that he can handle like escalations for Shivani and there's been enough knowledge transfer, then we'll be able to shift.
Yeah.
Vincent's schedule a couple hours, so that you know any of that morning stuff is being handled with with Sameer, and then Vincent and Shivani will continue to focus their energy on the cyber security, and our our percentages will, you know, look, our goal is to have everybody in a like a ninety-five percent proactive role, because I still...
I still ultimately think our time on reactive tickets either will continue to go down as we continue to, you know, standardize and also it's just a small, small fraction of what we do, right? Just those little reactive tickets that come in periodically. Some days are busier, some weeks are busier, some weeks are quieter on that front.
Yeah.
But we need to be 100% focused on being, you know, proactive engineers, right, that are building out our infrastructure, right, like we've talked about.
Yeah, and summer is going to, I know, I utilize most of the VMware side.
I'm sorry?
Sameer is going to be mostly work on the VMware side.
You know, I don't want to oversimplify what he's going to do in terms of that statement. Like he will work on, you know, one of the things that I think we learned with Anamesh is that to expand his scope too rapidly would be a really big problem, right? So there are some initial things that he's not doing that I think I'm going to.
Yeah.
Well, I know I have to give to Sameer to do, which include our entire infrastructure as a service and desktop delivery services to be responsible for, you know, Citrix. So, we'll need training on Citrix, you know, understanding, like you guys said, none of you guys have Citrix background, but it's not.
And you know, it's not any more difficult than anything else. None of this is rocket science, as me and Sameer have joked about before. You know, it's all pretty simple at the end of the day. It's all out of the box software, right? It's not like we're even doing a custom development at this point. I would love for us to do, you know, well, that's a different story again, right? The AI and all the development work, all the automation and things like that, which we need to expand.
Yeah.
No, no.
Definitely.
P.
Yeah.
related, Windows Server related, you know, understanding that layer between, you know, between VMware and guest OSs and, you know, the host operating system and the host hypervisor and underlying hardware and, you know, advanced, you know, any kind of escalations related to that stuff as well, Citrix, desktop delivery, networking.
you know, firewalls, you know, even the backup stuff, right? So there's that overlap with Anamesh. I think one of the first things is, you know, I think it's really sit down with Anamesh as well. Like, you know, now you have yourself, you have...
Okay.
The other gentleman that you mentioned, you guys got a Veeam guy that is going to give him, give give Anamesh support, but I think from a knowledge team sort of transfer, you know, making making sure Sameer is up to speed on how does the backup disaster recovery system work, you know, maybe update, make sure our documentation is all updated so it's clear.
Yeah, that's right. Support.
that multiple people can understand these things, right? That it's not a, you know, purely in somebody's head. This all has to be documented in various ways, right? In our runbooks and things like that.
No, that's so good. Yeah, so I think so. Sameer, I will probably put a request right to make sure in the second week of Zoom, the shift that is going to work. Yeah, Sameer.
Yeah, no, no, so I'm aligned with both the dates Alex is suggesting. Alex, hope you remember that I asked you during the last onboarding as well, is there any training which is on your tool stack? Because he's not doing anything for us, right? For 1st to 6th or 7th, he's going to be gently on the bench. I don't want to hassle him and then do nothing.
Do tell us the tool stack in which you want him to be, you know, aligned. Second thing, let's connect on 1st to do the pre-onboarding form set up with Rick. That does not require you to fill anything and the billing will not start until he's fully onboarded with you. That's on me, right? So there won't be any billing on 1st of June. That's my promise to you because I don't want you to pay for extra.
for which you are not getting the support. So just fill that form so that we can do our due diligence. You know, I think there was a onboarding form which Rick gets filled. Do you have that, Alex, already?
Mm.
Uh, let's see, um, I don't know.
Yeah.
Hello!
Also, Aman, if you can just work on the tech stack in which you can train him up so that he does not join APMIT half prepared, right? And he joins the day with all the accounts set up, with all the knowledge already, not all, I'm sure. There will be a lot which Alex will help him out, but...
30 to 40 percent you will have the tool step knowledge.
Sure, yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I didn't see an onboarding specific document. It just, that's not popping up.
Let me ask him if he can.
I can, I can, yeah, or I can share with you, Aleks.
Yeah, can you do that, Aman, please, right?
Yeah, go ahead and you can resend it to me if you may have already sent it. I just didn't.
Yeah.
And if you have any clarity or you need anything on that, Alex, we can jump on a quick call for 30 minutes on 1st. We can have that done. And again, then the tool stack training for whatever, like you have multiple tool stack, we will get that done from our end, right? My trainers and then again, Aman himself is highly technical. He can train him up.
Catcher.
So that he does not come half baked. Second thing, I don't know if Amit has already told you that you are supposed to get those credits for all the machines you have already bought. Yeah, so that is the main reason I am not saying, I'm not saying apologies for everything because I know that there is a delay.
Yeah.
Computers.
But we wanted to go through the right route, so I went back to Javid, hey, this is that, then he was right. Does not make sense to ask you to pay twice for the same sort of a thing. If we will only charge you for the delta, as simple as this, right? Which is like if there is any machine specification which is highly technical end or requires more money, then it is okay.
And that is what you're going to pay, right? That's why it took a little bit of more time. So me and Ankur, we were like, man, we are late again and we promised Alex. But again, we'll make sure that this happens in the right way. That's why I wanted to personally come onto this. Though I'm not running this account right now, but I'll always be engaged with you right throughout the onboarding. So because I know the institutional knowledge most.
since the day one along with Lee and I wanted to make sure that this guy also joins you well. Last thing I have, Alex, you remember that you have one more requirement of an engineer below Shivanu.
Right, I...
Yeah, I think what I need now is to make sure we can execute with the four we got. Like, there's a lot of execution. There's a lot of, I mean, yeah, there's a lot of work for us to do. I feel like we're at basically, I mean, once we have Sameer on board, we have about three times more work to do.
Mhm.
Mednis.
Fair enough, yeah.
per day than we're doing, ultimately. And once we get to that point, then, you know, everybody's firing on all cylinders, then I think we start looking at hiring more people. We're also hiring, just for your perspective, is we're hiring on the US side. So I'm also shifting a little bit of focus. We have a
Okay.
Makes complete sense, yeah.
Client success and operations manager coming on board, right? They'll be in a part-time role, but they'll be very visible, very involved with me day to day. Her name is Vanessa. And then we're also going to be hiring a...
Kip.
an associate account manager.
that will be working with all of our accounts. And this is building out our, you know, all of our requirements for us to get to that expansion that we're looking for, you know, our client expansion. So, you know, we're still, we're still, you know, we're finally maybe taking that turn around the corner to be able to grow the way that we set out to do at the beginning of the year. So.
Okay.
Amazing, yeah.
And.
Yeah.
Excellent. No, that makes more sense. Yeah.
And Alex and Sameer, Alex is also hiring me as a project manager from ITBD side.
Yes, this is true. This is true, actually. Well, you know, he wants to come work for us permanently. Is that what you're trying to say? All right.
I would love it. I have no issues.
No, no, from ITBD side.
Yeah, so, you know, we are a couple of things you have, a couple of asks on Aman you had sent from our last meeting regarding ConnectWise and especially, I've really given us a lot of thought. I really want to get you into our ConnectWise system so that you can really see what's going on very well.
Yeah, that's right.
So we got to figure that out. You know, regarding, of course, I understand APIs and I understand what permissions you're asking for, stuff like that. So we'll see what, without further documentation, I can do in that sense. I also want to establish what we talked about before, which was the APMIT.com.
Account for you, so that you can hop on calls, you know, with our customers to expand our, you know, new, you know, new services and delivery and Consulting, you know, Engineering projects and things like that. What do you got there, Sameer?
Alexa, I just pasted something for you because I know that you were very keen to work on the projects as well along with Aman. These are some of the projects that we have done for other clients as well, and Aman has been part of a lot of them, right? So he has been helping us there. So you can clearly see on the Intra side, Intune side, Antenna, AWS, S3.
Yeah.
And also for one of the biggest company which we work with is Omega, where we have worked on a lot of migrations from on-prem to cloud side, right? So do let us know whatever the possibilities. And it's not only Aman, we have around 12 engineers who work on this project side. So it's 24 17. Also, the availability will not be a challenge that that team is not working in EST and PSTs.
because there are a lot of cutovers that happens during the project, where a person needs to be maybe in IST shift to call it off. So just wanted to let you know and throw that ID in front of you. And again, Aman is a suitable and definitely a go to guy for you on that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, it is important for me to know capabilities because I can put things together very, very quickly in terms of opportunities with clients as well as expertise that we have on top and ready to go through you guys. There was something else I wanted to mention about this.
Project thing.
Um...
Yeah, if you want to specifically go through the entire process for this, I can have another call with Aman and also the project manager, the program manager who is running this, right? So let me know if you intend to. I can read that couple of SOWs as well and send it over for your review, right, in general. Be it any technology, we are well versed with all of them.
Okay, yeah, very good. I mean, there's, yeah. I mean, again, I...
But again, I know that you have a lot in plate as of now, so I'll not throw you under the bus. It is something we can we can probably look at the third quarter, right? Or maybe we can discuss in person value.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I just, I'm just trying to remember what I was trying to remember as you were saying this, but I forget what it was that I was trying to, trying to remember, but no, this is all, this is all very good, very, very good stuff, you know.
Yeah.
Very good.
Awesome.
Alright, I again wanted to personally tell you that why it took some time because I was working with Javid on the background, right? Hey, this is this is what we need to do. Alex is a special person now for us and I want to extend this team right as simple as this. I don't want to make you unhappy. We had our hurdles in the starting.
Yeah.
Kip.
ITBD by design. I was called, this is the first time I was called a very special person.
Now the team is there now for you to support, Alex. So you remember it was only me in the starting, then we had Lee joining the party. Now Amit is there, Aman is there, and Ankur is there from the CX team, right? So we do care for you and there's a whole team which works internally as well. And Aman is really sensitive for you. He keeps on emailing me and Amit, guys, I need you to handle this, right? I need you to handle this. Alex is unhappy.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, I told, I told, I told him I was going to be noisy this week, and it's only, you know, we've only been at work for a total of like 12 hours since the weekend, so you know.
Right, so I'm just telling you the truth here.
No.
No, I am completely understand the bit of frustration which comes in when you're not getting the answers because from your end, you only ask for communication. That is what you want. That is what you have always asked for. So I'm hoping to communicate more and also keep you not in dark whatever is happening at our end as well.
Yeah, look, and in terms of hiring more people, like, look, as long as we are, I mean, honestly, the faster we execute, I'm not, I don't want to slow down. I mean, the faster we execute, then, because all it's doing is slowing down my revenue growth, right? So the better we execute,
Yeah.
the better we put all the pieces in place, then we will move to the next step, right? We're gonna move to the next step as soon as all these pieces are in place. And we need to, honestly, me and Aman, I have to talk about it. Me, Amit, Aman, whoever else we gotta talk to because.
It just me, it's a very symbiotic relationship. I mean, we have a very, very good symbiotic relationship. And if I...
If we achieve the success around these, you know, four folks that we've got on board, what I consider the definition of success, we will be...
I mean, we will be able to fly, right? I'm less concerned about the other projects. I'm more concerned about selling our core services, right? Like our cybersecurity and risk management program, right? I have to, I do need to fold in a little bit more AI conversation because that's just a requirement today, but our cybersecurity and risk management program.
Yeah.
is once we're ready to, once we have all of our tech stack in place and our existing customers, we'll be able to really roll. And we're gonna be able to roll fast. Now we are, we are working, I say this with a little bit of trepidation because of how quickly the entire...
environment, the world is shifting right below our feet at such a rapid pace. So where we were, I mean, that's the bigger concern is like.
Yeah, indeed. Yeah.
Is the stuff that we ultimately want to sell going to be irrelevant? You know, by the time we're ready to sell it, or are we going to be at a, are we going to be somewhere where we're still extremely relevant? But I think cybersecurity obviously is extremely relevant, right?
Yeah.
It is, it is, yeah.
So, you know, to say that would become irrelevant would be a silly thing, but we might need to, the question is how quickly are we going to need to enhance that offering, you know, based on the current landscape, because I built it based on technology from a year ago or technology based on, you know, 12 to 18 months ago and what else do I need to incorporate, right?
Yeah.
So, it's always a bit of a, you know, cat and mouse game here, right, with that in that regard, but then that's the only trepidation I have, but I feel like, again, we're hiring account managers for this reason, or or or that's what we're building.
on the sales side so that we can, number one, serve our existing customers because one of the things that we've done is we've eliminated IT resources in the United States and I can feel the discomfort from our customers, right? Even though it makes no sense, right? Because they're like,
Yeah.
Like, well, we want to call and talk to Jim, you know, like, well, well, oh, Jim's no longer with you. He's been terminated. And they're like, oh my gosh, what, what? Wait, we got to talk to somebody in India for support, you know? And they're like freaking out, right? And it's like, no, you don't understand. This is actually very
good for you, but so we have to now, you know, flush out the US side on the account management side so that, you know, the customers feel like more connected. Because for whatever reason, they want to, like, somehow they picture the fact that somebody sitting in an office within, you know, the Philadelphia area.
Makes a difference to the way.
No, I completely understand that. They will flush out, they want to talk to more in America, that accent, that connect, that the human feeling which they feel from US might not be here, 40,000 miles away. So that I have seen in other accounts as well. Then Posh, I would say that is
partly there, partly not, right, for all the accounts I would say. Also, it's a shift game right now, Alex, right? Not all of them are okay with it. Some of them have actually made, okay, that's fine. We just need the support at the end of the day. But again, some of the customer, I'm sure on the account management side, would appreciate the effort that you're putting in to hire somebody locally. That will flush that out.
Yeah, yeah, locally, you know, a touch point that they can speak to every day that is obviously, you know, taking care of them. They'll feel certainly a lot more comfortable with that. The other thing is, that's why I always try to stress to my own team, and I know that they don't do it, like get on a Zoom call, get on a Teams call with our customers, like, you know,
Yeah.
Shivani, go ahead with the cameras on, talk to the customer. And that's why I also want to get them on on calls with our customers. Like I want to make sure this feels like a fully integrated team with our customers, right? It doesn't feel like it's 20,000 miles away or 10,000 miles away because it's, it shouldn't feel that way, you know.
We're all one team and I think we can leverage that. It takes a little bit of effort, but we can make that happen.
Patel.
Yeah, the internal, internal, I think the motto that the team or Kam when she was here in India, that's our direction as well, one team, one dream and one direction. That's what we feel in as of now, internally as well, and I'm sure that we can align our partners into that for sure.
Yeah, I saw that on the on LinkedIn. I saw a picture of that banner. Yeah. Well, anyway, so very good. A couple of things I got, I'm on, and I think from our last call, and I appreciate the work that you're doing on Amesh. That's very helpful.
Yeah.
Yep.
I was definitely, as you could see through my text or my team's chat yesterday, I was like, I don't know what to do at this point. I mean, but very nice turnaround on that and hopefully,
You know, hopefully, I think he, you know, soft skills, there's some soft skills training there too, right? That's needed. Time management skills and prioritization, which I talked to him about yesterday. And I think he just, he does, he does respond well to it. Hopefully he'll remember. And he can structure his schedule well and get a lot done in his eight hour stretch and not feel like.
He's just sort of floundering around. He doesn't need to flounder around. He has, if at any point he has a doubt regarding direction, just let me know.
No, no, definitely. I mean, he's aligned, right? So, because I know he moved from enterprise level to an MSP and everything is, he worked on infra where everything was set up already, right? So, so this is the first time him to build everything from the scratch, you know, saw the environment, how it's gonna build and what all efforts support that he is required, so...
He's aligned, so I am dedicatedly working with him. The person is closely aligned, so make sure he get all the support. And the good thing I was sharing with him, because when I saw your, you know, message on the team, even if the cloud, you know, the limit is full, let me know. I will upgrade and pay for the extra, which is a good thing.
You have given all the, you know, the tool access paid license for everything, and you know they should get benefit using those all tool, you know, get the maximum benefit out of it, you know, using their own brain.
Yeah, alright, well, I'm good. Is there anything else you wanna add, Aman?
No, I think we're good. So I have you doodle and...
Yeah, we good, we good, yep.
So yeah, let me know another piece which is about, we discuss about the kind of more visibility about their productivity, what all they're doing, right? So just kind of overview, rather going to sit individually and you know, looking in their system, what all they're doing. So if I have a centralized place where I can monitor watch from.
What says?
The other side, and if needed any support, I can jump immediately, you know.
Okay, what do you mean by actually you want me to have their screens on your screen? You want me to like just have...
No.
So I think maybe I'm not that's what I think we had the discussions pending. So whatever they are doing, right? So how would I monitor what all they're doing, right? If you have given a task in the morning, whether that completed the recent one that we were discussing this morning about the server upgrade. So either the one way I go proactive and check with him what all you have done, how many.
server you upgraded, if you need any support, kind of, you know, checking individually, right? But if I have something in a centralized where I can see what all he's doing, what all task has been completed, how he has planned his day, you know, all kind of those things.
Okay, awesome. Yeah, well, we'll get all that straight. This all just takes some time, right? We're all heading in the right direction and it just takes time for us to get there. But I think we're making, you know, phenomenal progress, you know, and, you know, we're going to get there. So next step is next step.
Yeah.
Yeah, agreed. Yeah, and the good thing we you always reach out on the team, which is a really good thing I like about it, because we don't wanna wait for weekly call, we happen to this on Monday, then we're discussing this on Thursday, right? We're discussing the same time immediately, so I can proactive him support him, you know, we can make those changes and we can make those improvement.
Okay.
So, yeah.
Thank you so much, Aman. I appreciate it. Yeah. Yeah, no, I think that's right. So, you know, we want to shorten the cycles and make sure, you know, we address things right on, right at the right time immediately when needed. So thank you so much. All right.
Yeah.
Great. Thank you so much, Kam. Alexis, have a good day. Enjoy the rest of your day. Bye, bye.
Thank you. Bye.
Alright, talk to you guys later. Bye bye.